قال المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الايرانيه ناصر
كنعاني ان الاتفاق النوويه على الطاوله
ولا تزال هناك ارضيه للتوصل الاتفاق واضاف
كنعاني في مؤتمر الصحفي الاسبوعيه انما
واقف واشنطن بشان المفاوضات النوويه
متناقضه واجراءتها غير البناء تاخر التوسل
الاتفاق
النووي لا يزال على الطاوله ولا تزال هناك
ارضيه لتوسل الاتفاق لكن مع الاسف نهجو
واشنطن لا يزال مرتبكا ومترددا ومواقفها
متناقضه واذا ما اتخذ الطرف الاخر
واجراءات فيمكن توصل الى اتفاق وتنفيذه نص
الاتفاق الذي تم التفاوض بشانه جاهز
للتوقيع لكن يتعالوا للطرف الامريكي
واجراءاته غير البناء هي التي تحول دون
ذلك ما يهمه ايرانه واتخاذ الطرف المقابل
اجراءات عمليه وننتظر اتخاذها ايران لا
تربط مصيرها بالاتفاق النووي فهو احد
ملفات السياسه الخارجيه ولن يغادر طاوله
المفاوضات وسنواصل هذا النهج ما دام الطرف
الاخر ملتزما به خصوصه هاميه
مع السعوديه قال كنعانين الرياضه وطهران
متفقتان على مواصله المحادثات بينهما
ويمكنهما عقد جوله جديده في بغداد واضاف
ان الحوار بين وزيرين خارجيه ايران
والسعوديه الاخير في الاردن كان بناء
ومعبرا عن استعدادهما لمواصله الحوار
سياستنا واضحه بشان الحوار مع السعوديه
الحوار وفي ظل الاجواء الحاليه يمكن عقد
جوله جديده في بغداد الاصدقاء